Good evening, everybody.
My name is Paul Fero. I'm currently at Cedars-Sinai
Health Sciences University. That's our new name.
We used to be Cedars-Sinai Medical Center.
And I hope you're all enjoying what, for me, has been a
great meeting in a wonderful location.
I've really enjoyed being in San Diego, and it's my great
honor
to serve as the chair of the selection committee for the AACR
and American Cancer Society Award for Research Excellence in
Cancer Epidemiology and Prevention.
We're going to start by inviting Dr.
William Dahut of the American Cancer Society to make a few initial
remarks. Dr. Dahut.
Thanks, Paul.
Well, we're very excited to sponsor this
award,
for Research Excellence in Cancer Epi and Prevention.
Actually, the award has been going on since
1992, which is actually before I actually went to an
AACR meeting, so that actually is a long time ago.
And
I'm particularly excited that it's going to be Elizabeth Platz, who I've known
for a long time, for her work in prostate cancer.
We spent time together on the DoD Integration Panel.
She's another Marylander up the road, so it's really wonderful
to talk about someone who has an understanding of molecular biology,
cancer epi, with really an eye, obviously, ultimately, to some prevention.
From the ACS perspective,
our relationship with AACR is very important,
and we really have
strong plans to actually strengthen this relationship.
We've had conversations with Dr. Foti.
She's educated me on multiple times how AACR was there first, and it was an
AACR person, Dr. Ewing, who inspired ACS.
I don't think she was there then, but I'm not going to argue with Marge.
She might have been there. But no, I
think you'll hear over time,
the importance that AACR is to the American Cancer Society.
AACR obviously is the world's premier organization of research
professionals in the cancer world, and we feel that
we obviously, we're the largest funder of cancer research outside
the US government, at least in this country,
and have a strong commitment as a patient-focused organization.
So working together is a great thing for science, great things for
patients, and will be a great thing for this lecture. So thank you very much.
Thank you, Dr. Dahut. Before I continue,
particularly for those of you who are not in the room in person, because this is
also being live-streamed and is in other rooms,
the QR code that you can see up on screen at the moment,
is to enable you to ask
questions which will come up on my screen during the course of the talk, and then
I can feed those back,
given some time at the end. So without further ado,
I would like to say on behalf of the officers and directors of the
AACR board, to extend our sincerest thanks to our
colleagues at the American Cancer Society for the continued collaboration
and enduring support,
through this partnership.
The AACR has the honor and privilege of administering this prestigious
scientific achievement
award every year. So thank you very much to the ACS for that.
As Dr. Dahut has already told you, this award was initiated in
1992,
and its purpose is to recognize investigators whose research has led to
major advances in cancer epidemiology,
biomarkers, and prevention.
It reflects a long-standing commitment of the AACR to
cancer prevention and population sciences, priorities that have been woven into
the fabric of the AACR since the founding in 1907,
and one of the founding members of the organization was a pioneer in cancer
prevention. So this year's honoree is a leader in cancer
epidemiology whose work
has significantly advanced our understanding of prostate cancer development,
progression, and outcomes. The 2026
AACR-American Cancer Society Award for Research Excellence in
Cancer Epidemiology and Prevention is presented to Dr. Elizabeth A.
Platz. Dr. Platz is a professor of epidemiology at
the Johns Hopkins Bloomberg School of Public Health with
joint appointments in oncology and urology at the Johns Hopkins University
School of Medicine.
She's internationally recognized for her leadership in cancer epidemiology and
for research that has deepened our understanding of the biological
and lifestyle factors that influence prostate cancer development, progression, and
outcomes.
Throughout her career, Dr. Platz has advanced population-based
translational research, integrating epidemiology with
pathology, genetics, and basic science to uncover mechanisms of
disease and inform prevention strategies.
Among her most influential contributions is her work on the role of inflammation in
prostate cancer. In collaboration with Dr.
Angelo De Marzo, she demonstrated that intraprostatic inflammation
contributes to prostate cancer development, helping establish
inflammation as a driver of cancer
etiology.
Dr. Platz has also made important contributions to understanding cancer
progression and risk. Her work on telomere
biology showed that men with clinically localized prostate
cancer face a significantly higher risk of death when the
tumors exhibit both greater variability in telomere length among
cancer cells and shorter telomeres in the surrounding
stromal tissue.In parallel, her
epidemiological studies demonstrated that long-term statin use
is associated with a reduced risk of aggressive disease, and this is
supported by complementary laboratory findings.
She's also led studies identifying existing FDA-approved drugs that might be
repurposed for cancer prevention or treatment.
Through a multidisciplinary approach combining laboratory screening and
epidemiological investigation, she and her colleagues identified the
cardiac medication digoxin as a potential candidate for targeting
prostate cancer pathways. Dr. Platz's impact
extends beyond her own research. She is a respected leader
and mentor, directing the Hopkins training program in Cancer
Epidemiology Prevention and Control, and serving as editor-in-chief of the
AACR journal, "Cancer Epidemiology Biomarkers &
Prevention." She also serves on the AACR Board of Directors
and contributes extensively to AACR scientific programs and
initiatives.
She has also demonstrated a strong commitment to translating research into public
health impact, contributing to state and national cancer control
efforts, including the Surgeon General's report on smoking and health.
Her contributions have been widely recognized, including election as a fellow
of the American Association for the Advancement of Science.
Through her scientific leadership, collaborative spirit, and dedication to
improving cancer prevention and control, Dr.
Platz has made lasting contributions to the fields of cancer
epidemiology prevention. So, it's my great honor to introduce
the 2026 recipient of the AACR American Cancer
Society Award for Research Excellence in Cancer
Epidemiology and Prevention, Dr. Elizabeth A. Platz.
Thank you so much. Thanks, Paul.
Thanks, Bill. Thanks to AACR and to the American Cancer Society
for this honor. I am so excited to receive this award.
All right. So I'm going to talk about exactly what Paul just
described, and then I'll tell you a little bit more about the research we've been
doing recently. I do want to take a moment to recognize the people
who came before me, who received this award. There's so many of them.
Dr. Fraumeni, back in 1993, won this award.
When I was a high school student, I drove myself over to the
National Cancer Institute and met with Dr.
Fraumeni, and he helped me to understand more about cancer
epidemiology, and he connected me with Neil Caporaso, and I spent a little
bit of time in his group learning about family study.
Some of you remember
both of them.
Then the people who mentored me, so Ed Giovannucci was my postdoc mentor,
and he was mentored and collaborated with Meir Stampfer and Graham Colditz,
who's here, and Walter Willett. So they all played a role in my
development during my postdoc years and then early in my career, and
actually still to this day. Again, Graham's sitting right there.
He has served on external advisory boards for various
projects that I had, my T32. So I'm grateful to all of
them for how they helped shape my career.
And then with respect to the journal, Fred Li, I took his course
when I was a doctoral student, and at some point when he was the
editor-in-chief, he came to me and said, "You're a really good
reviewer," and he appointed me to what became the editorial board.
And then through that, eventually,
I just kept reviewing and was recognized by the editor-in-chief at the time,
Tim Rebbeck, and I became a senior editor for the journal.
So all these colleagues have received this award over the years.
So again, such a huge honor to be among them now.
Okay, here are my disclosures. So I'm going to mention non-FDA approved use
of drugs, but these drugs are
standard drugs, so aspirin,
lipid-lowering drugs, statins, and digoxin.
Okay, so the themes of this talk are on collaborating for discovery and
confirmation. I am a team scientist.
The vast majority of the grants that I've had have been parts of
PO1s or P50s. I've had a few independent by
myself type awards, but I tend to work collaboratively, and I'm the one that
brings epidemiology to the research.
I also want to talk a bit about opportunities to bridge
epidemiology with basic science, and here what I mean
is going from our findings in epidemiology back to basic
science to understand causation and mechanism, to figure
out, can we take action to intervene?
I'll also talk about leveraging data and biospecimens in epidemiologic research,
and then opportunities for cancer prevention and prognostication.
Okay, so prostate cancer. How did I become a prostate cancer
epidemiologist? Well, it was Ed Giovannucci.
So I originally went to work with him on his trial on
colorectal cancer. He was doing a folate trial, and one day he came
to me and said, "Oh, we've got these projects on prostate cancer.
Do you want to get involved?" And I said, "Sure. I'll do anything.
I'm trying to learn here." And so the first one was on vasectomy and
prostate cancer,
in India. And then after that, I started working in the Health Professionals
Follow-up Study on prostate cancer.
So I'm grateful to Ed for this
early in my career opportunity.
Okay, so then how did I become involved with basic
translational scientists? Well, again, it
was Ed.
At some point, he received a throwaway
article. It was not really an article.
It's like a throwaway publication for physicians,
and he was invited by that
newsletter. It was called "New Developments in Prostate Cancer Treatment." They
asked him to write a little piece on STI, sexually
transmitted infections in prostate cancer,
and he knew that I was interested in inflammation and STIs in prostate cancer.
He said, "Here, do you want to write it?
They'll pay you $75."So I wrote that
piece.
And it was noticed by Bill Nelson, who at the time was early in his career.
He's now our cancer center director and a prostate cancer medical oncologist
and researcher.
And so he noticed the article, and he went to Angelo De Marzo, who you heard his
name.
Angelo was studying inflammation.
He's a pathologist, a molecular pathologist, and he was very early in his
career, I think he was still in training.
And he was studying intraprostatic inflammation in
the context of prostate cancer. So Bill said, "Hey, this woman's going to
beat you to the punchline."
Well, it turned out we come from different disciplines.
So Ed and Bill connected Angelo and me, and now
we've had more than 25 years of research together because of that
endorsement.
Okay, so here we are. So you can see Angelo and me, and then Allan Meeker and me.
You heard about telomeres. And so the strategy we've used all these years is
an iterative approach. By the way, Lorelei Mucci called this
pathoepidemiology. So we'd been doing it for a while, but we just hadn't named it.
So she came up with a terrific name.
So the idea is that my colleagues have developed
interesting questions using basic science approaches.
So they test their hypotheses, they have interesting findings, and they tend to
come to me and they say, "Is there a way to study this in people?"
And then we do our research together, and then the goal is to actually iterate
back. And this is the hard part. So my last remarks are actually going to be about
that point. And this has worked really well for us
in prostate cancer at my institution and then in collaboration with
Harvard and other
institutions because of this general collaborative spirit that we have,
collegiality, generosity, trust, and we have shared goals of
discovery and translation specific to prostate cancer.
And it turns out that our team is quite extensive across disciplines.
We have urology, we've got genetics and so on, immunology.
And at my institution, I've collaborated with a lot of people.
These are really great opportunities because we're bringing a method.
So these are epidemiology-anchored studies.
We bring a method where we can study in people.
We bring their basic science and clinical and translational
discoveries, and then we study it in people using epi approaches.
Okay, so here's the first story. This is about intraprostatic inflammation.
So you heard some of the punchlines already.
So working with Angelo,
we put together a project that was part of a program project
in the prostate cancer prevention trial.
So as that trial was nearing its completion, a letter was sent to
investigators across the country for projects
to embed within the data and samples that had been
collected as part of that trial. So that trial tested whether
finasteride would reduce the occurrence of prostate
cancer. This drug inhibits
the enzyme that catalyzes the conversion of testosterone to
dihydrotestosterone.
So they thought it would reduce the occurrence of prostate cancer.
What's great about this trial from my perspective is that they
biopsied the men at the end of the trial, irrespective of whether
they had indication. And the reason is the study drug reduces PSA
level.
But those biopsies were really valuable for our research
question because they were not done for
indication. I'll show you in a moment that it's well
recognized that when there's inflammation in the
prostate, that can cause PSA to leak into circulation.
So if you're using PSA
as the reason for biopsy,
you're going to find a lot of inflammation, and of course, when you biopsy it,
you're going to find prostate cancer.
So that would have forced an association between inflammation and prostate cancer.
So using the end of study biopsies in this trial allowed us to have an
unbiased look at the relationship between intraprostatic inflammation
and prostate cancer. That's long-winded, but very important to the hypothesis.
Okay, so after a couple of tries, the PO1 was funded,
and this was done in collaboration with SWOG and
investigators at a number of locations in the country.
So for our project, and by the way, this paper was published in CBP before I was
the editor-in-chief, and you'll notice a theme that many of the papers are in
ACR journals. Okay, so what we found was that intraprostatic
inflammation, this is again with Angelo, is associated with an
increased likelihood of prostate cancer.
The pathology fellow who did a lot of this work was Bora Gurall, who's now a
full-fledged investigator. So it's a little while ago.
So we were very excited about this, but this is actually not a prospective
study. We used the end of study biopsies that
were used to determine whether there was prostate cancer present or not.
So it's not temporally correct.
So I said that out loud. This is where collaboration is so important.
I said it out loud at one of our meetings,
and the head biostatistician for the trial, Phyllis Goodman,
said, "Wait a minute."
I said out loud that we'll never be able to study this in a prospective way.
And she said, "But you can, because some of the men in the prostate cancer
prevention trial who didn't have prostate cancer by the end enrolled in the
next trial called SELECT, and they were followed for prostate cancer."
And this meant that the end of study biopsies in PCPT became the
baseline biopsies for SELECT. We were able to
study prospectively the relationship between intraprostatic
inflammation and prostate cancer risk.
And what we found was that as the mean percent area
that was inflamed in the prostate tissue, as that increased, so did the risk
of prostate cancer.
So this is the first and probably only study that's done
prospectively on this topic because men don't really want to be
biopsied for no reason. So we're really lucky that this trial
exists. Okay, and then just to show you that, in
fact, there is a relationship between PSA and
inflammation. This is again in the PCPT work done by Martin Hubert, who was a
postdoc with me some time ago. So as PSA level
increases-The median percent tissue area inflamed
goes up. Okay? So this is in men who do not have a clinical
indication for biopsy. Their PSA is low, and they have a normal DRE.
Okay, so our supposition that we worried about that bias,
we can see it here.
All right. So then we're always interested in, well, what's causing the
inflammation?
And one of the hypotheses
is infection.
Siobhan Sutcliffe, when she was a doctoral student and then a post-section alpha
professor at Wash U in Graham's department,
as part of the PCPT, we went ahead and added her interest to that
original project, and we didn't see associations
between antibodies and these outcomes.
Nevertheless, we were still interested in trying to understand whether
having these infections, not just antibodies against them, but actually having
these infections would increase the likelihood of intraprostatic
inflammation. And so working with Bill and Angelo,
we came up with the idea that PSA can be our marker for
intraprostatic inflammation. I just showed you there's a relationship.
So what Siobhan did is she worked with a couple of STI clinics in
Baltimore City and identified...
It was all
blinded. She didn't know who the men were.
But she was able to obtain blood specimens, pre and post-convalescent.
And then we were able to take a look at whether there was a relationship
between genitourinary infections as well as circulating
infections, and whether they're related to PSA level in young men.
And then the rate of decline in PSA,
because it turned out she did see associations, the rate of decline as
they convalesced. She was able to repeat that study in the DoD Serum
Repository. And Marvin Langston, who was a student with
her, and now he's an assistant professor at Stanford, was very much involved in
these studies. As her career progressed, she continued to train people, too.
Okay. So now Coco Lin, who's in the audience.
So we're all collaborating together. And again, this is still the PCPT.
We're still trying to understand what's causing intraprostatic inflammation.
And so Siobhan had measured as part of that original PCPT
project,
several HPV types. Now these are antibodies against these types.
Okay, so HPV types are the common ones that cause cervical cancer,
HHV-8, T. vaginalis, and importantly,
cytomegalovirus. So this virus is obviously a systemic
infection. You don't clear it. There's a little bit of evidence that it
may infect the prostate.
Okay. So what Coco's doing is she's investigating
whether seropositivity for CMV compared to
being seronegative for all of the agents that we're
investigating. She's investigating whether having
seropositivity is related to a greater percent
tissue area and also just binary, whether there's a relationship at
all. And that's what she sees. She sees that being
seropositive for CMV,
and this is with or without other infections, or only
having CMV, they're all positively associated with the
extent of intraprostatic inflammation.
She also sees that being seropositive for other agents combined seems to be
associated, but not as strongly.
Okay. She's also looking at the relationship between aging and
intraprostatic inflammation in the PCPT.
All those years we'd been studying
inflammation in PCPT, we never bothered to look at age.
We always just adjusted for it. We assumed that inflammation would go up with age,
and in fact, that's what she sees. Okay, again, in PCPT.
So as quartile of age goes up, she sees that the likelihood of
intraprostatic inflammation goes up, and this is adjusted for a number of factors.
Okay. And very interestingly to me,
the immune cell type that seems to increase with age is
FoxP3, which is what's also seen in circulation with age.
Okay. So,
the other area that Angela really has spent a lot of time studying is focal
atrophy. So he has named focal atrophy when it's
inflamed, proliferative inflammatory atrophy.
And as part of our PCPT project, he developed,
not a survey, but it was
an early online tool that could show images
of atrophy and other kinds of lesions, and then the subtypes of atrophy.
And then he invited pathology colleagues, junior all the way through
to very seasoned pathologists, to be able to go in
and diagnose atrophy versus other lesions and the
type. And so we did an analysis, and it turned out they're pretty good.
Pathologists can tell you it's atrophy, and they can kind of tell you the type of
atrophy. So this was really important for the work that we were doing in PCPT.
So in PCPT,
this is Shore Tsang. What she did is she looked in the
prior placebo arm. So these are people who participate in
PCPT and then in SELECT. Okay, so we're looking at
their baseline biopsy and then risk of prostate cancer.
So men who were previously in the placebo arm and in the
finasteride arm previously. And what she saw
was no association between atrophy.
We thought it would be positively associated, no association in the prior
placebo arm. This is none of the cores were positive, some, and all.
So no association. But in the men who were in the prior
finasteride arm, we see an inverse association.
So none of the cores with inflammation, some, and all. So inverse relationship.
And we think what she's seeing is that the men who were
responsive to the study drug, which we think causes
focal atrophy, are the ones that were having the benefit of
finasteride. Because again, the trial showed an inverse
relationship. So the period prevalence was lower in the men in the finasteride arm.
So we think that's what she's detecting here.
Okay, and then we also adjusted for inflammation.
When we did that, the association was even stronger.All right.
So now the telomere story. So when I first started at
Hopkins as faculty, Alan Meeker, who's a telomere
biologist, had just developed a method to
measure telomere length at single-cell resolution
using a fluorescence technique.
And I was the analyst. I was faculty, but I'm the one that analyzed the data,
comparing how short the telomeres were
in the prostate cancer cells versus normal prostate
epithelial cells. And so we kept talking about, what other
work could we do? And so with Angelo, we thought we should investigate
whether there's any prognostic significance to the short telomeres
in the prostate cancer cells.
So that's all well and good. You have to write a grant, which we did on a train
coming back from a prostate cancer meeting. The grant was funded.
We were very excited about it.
And so we started doing the work. This was in collaboration with Ed and
Mayor and Lorelei Mucci, and this is using the materials of the Health
Professionals Follow-up Study. For the men with prostate cancer, they had
collected their tissue from their prostatectomy, so they have clinically localized
disease, and they'd made tissue microarrays so that we could
efficiently measure telomere length.
It still took five years to do this work, so it's very
labor-intensive to be able to measure.
This is still the case because it's individual cell
resolution. Okay, and so what we noticed was it wasn't
short telomeres in the prostate cancer cells that was related to
prognosis.
It was the variability. So from cell, so this is prostate cancer cell
to prostate cancer cell. It was the variability in the telomere
length that seemed to be most important.
Okay, so here's the variability. So this is taking the standard deviation.
We noticed that two of the tertiles seemed to have the same association, so we put
them together. Okay, so we made it binary.
And then we looked in the stromal cells, and what we noticed was in the
stromal cells, it was how short the telomeres were that was related to risk.
Okay, so we were going to stop here. We thought this was exciting.
But then Chris Heaphy, who was the postdoc at the time working with us,
he's now an associate professor,
said, "What if we put them together?
I wonder if there's information in the joint categories." By the way, here's the
Telomere Express story of us being on the train.
So we put those
two categories together, and so here's the outcome, prostate cancer death.
Again, these are men who had clinically localized disease.
It's the Health Professionals Follow-up Study.
They're followed forward in time for the development of mets
and death from prostate cancer. And what we found was that the men
who had variability, greater variability in telomere length
from cancer cell to cancer cell, combined with short telomeres in the stroma,
they had 14 times the risk of progression to death from
prostate cancer. And this is adjusting for the
standard tumor prognostic indicators.
Okay, and this is both compared to less variable, longer telomeres, and men
with the two intermediate combinations had intermediate risk.
We also saw that for lethal disease, which means progression to mets.
Now, interestingly, for biochemical recurrence, it was only the variability
in telomere length in the cancer cells that seemed to be related to risk.
Okay, and again, this is great work done by Chris Heaphy.
And then this is my longtime collaborator, Alan Meeker, and of course, the health
professionals colleagues. All right, so we said, "This is great. That's one study.
We need to replicate this." So then we had to write two more grants to get enough
money to be able to look at this in several studies.
And so this is like a meta-analysis of our own data.
And so here's the same association for prostate cancer death, strong p-value,
not quite as strong. It's almost five instead of being 14.
And then recurrence became even stronger for specifically
the variability in the cancer cells.
So this, to me, was really exciting.
We tried to go through the process of patenting it, but
then it turned out we had Chris, as a postdoc,
present his findings
at a conference, which meant we gave away the rights, the international rights
to patent. And so nobody wanted to touch this.
And then on top of it, this is a hard assay to do.
It's not yet translatable to standard clinical labs.
So this is not a tool that's being used, even though there's notable
prognostic information in this
tool. Okay. So Chris continued doing
work on
telomere length, and so again, stromal cells.
This is looking at risk in the PCPT.
So he found that shorter stromal, this is below the median, is
associated with a higher risk of prostate cancer.
And then he was also interested in racial differences.
So Black men have a much higher risk of aggressive prostate cancer and lethal
disease. So we looked at our telomere biomarker, which is that combination of
variability and length in the stromal cells, and also
decomposing it to just the variable in the cancer and shorter
in the cancer-associated stromal cells.
It turned out it was the variability in cancer cells that seemed to differ between
Black and white men. Okay, so there's more aggressive disease, and this is
all men with higher grade disease.
Okay. So this is still a related story. So this is Cori Joshyu.
She was a postdoc with me, and
now she's a very senior associate professor.
And so when she was early in her training and career, she became
interested in understanding factors that influence the
recurrence of prostate cancer. And so she looked
at weight gain.
So men who tended to gain weight from before their
diagnosis to after their surgery had a higher risk of
recurrence. Okay, so we thought this was very exciting.
In fact, one of the urologists, when he saw this, said he started counseling his
patients not to gain weight after their
diagnosis. Okay. So then what she said was, "Let's look
at telomere length in the stromal cells.
Is there any relationship with obesity and physical activity?" And
what she found, this is in the health professionals, is that men who were obese and
had lower physical activity had 21% shorter
telomeres in their stromal cells.
So maybe this is a biological effect.
Maybe it's justChance? We don't
know. So she got some money, and so she tried this again
in multiple studies, and she's confirmed it now in five clinical TMA
sets, different kinds of populations.
And so she was funded by the Prostate Cancer Foundation for that work.
All right. So then we thought, well, there's something interesting going on.
We've got inflammation, we've got telomeres. So this is our latest work.
I don't have answers for you yet for this.
This is five years of work. It's two big grants.
We noticed that there was an emerging
literature on senescent stromal fibroblasts.
They elaborate
cytokines and growth factors. And we thought, well, maybe the short telomeres that
we're seeing in the stromal cells are fibroblasts that are
senescent, and maybe they're calling in that inflammatory
response.
Now, this is a great hypothesis.
Do you know there's no way
in these kinds of fixed tissues to truly know if a cell is a
fibroblast?
And there's no single marker to tell us if they're senescent.
So we tried to back into it by using multiple markers.
Now, our goal was to be able to look at those markers in the
same cell.
Originally, we were going to have to do separate sections.
The technologies have advanced.
Angela De Marzo has developed techniques where we can actually erase the markers,
the antibodies,
and restain.
So now we have multiple markers,
but we have to do the fluorescence separate from the chromogenic for all of our
markers. And we have two different tools for doing the image
analysis. And then we have to register the images.
One of the tools stitches together the images, and sometimes it's
imperfect. AI is not perfect, and it's made it hard to do the
registration. So five years' worth of work, we're still working on it.
But I will show you a little bit of data. It's always a problem, right?
It's real research. So I will show you a little bit of data that we've generated so
far. So one of the markers of, we think, senescence is
lamin B1. This is work that Judith Campisi
did years ago,
showing that it seems to be lower when fibroblasts senesce.
So we picked that marker. Lamin B1 is a network of
filaments. It kind of holds the chromatin
so that it's in place, because the chromosomes exist in space within
the nucleus. So our hypothesis is that short
telomeres and low lamin B1 should go together
if the cells are senescent.
And that's what we see. So now here's Drew Burke. He's the biostatistician.
What's shown on the x-axis is quintile of telomere length.
Q5, the longest, is the reference here.
And what's shown on the y-axis is low lamin B1.
And what we see is as telomere lengths are shorter, the likelihood of having
low lamin B1 is higher. So this is the first time this has been shown for
prostate.
Okay, so other stories, statin drugs.
You heard this was something that
we were known for. So this work came about because
a colleague of mine in the PCPT, we were already working together, happened
to see a case control study, and it was the first one that showed this
relationship. And he said, "Hey, have you tried to study this?" And I said, "No, we
have not." So we went ahead and worked with Ed and
Walter, and Mayer, and this is Health Professionals Follow-up Study.
And what we noticed was there was no association between statin drug use
and risk of prostate cancer. So then we said, "Well, maybe
it's lethal disease that's important." It turned out that's what it was.
We found an inverse association between statin drug use and
metastatic disease, and death from prostate cancer, especially if men used it
for the long term.
Well, this was then further supported by work, I'm going to tell you the details of
this work in a moment. It's basically a drug screen that Bill Nelson
and Vasan Yagnasubramanian did with Jun Lu, who's a
pharmacologist at our institution.
And in this drug screen, these are prostate cancer cell lines.
Some are androgen-dependent, some are androgen-independent.
Some of the top hits happen to be statins.
So this is cytotoxic,
so it's cell killing. It's an assay for cell killing.
And so again, a couple of the top hits happen to be statins, which we feel kind of
reinforces, gives a little bit of a causal explanation.
This is work from Alison Mondal, who's right there in the audience, and this is in
the ARIC cohort. So she took a look.
We were trying to find as many studies as we could to try to substantiate this
finding. So she took a look at incident and fatal prostate cancer.
And what was great about her study was she was able to have very long-term statin
use, and different from most studies that had short-term statin use, she was able
to look at very long-term, including 10 plus years.
And when she did that, the association was present for fatal disease, but also for
incident disease. Okay. What underlies this?
We're always interested in mechanism. We took a look at cholesterol.
That's an obvious one, given that we saw the statins association.
So this is modeled for low cholesterol
versus high to match what you'd get for statin drugs, because you're low in
cholesterol. And what we saw was an inverse association
for high-grade disease.
And then Phyllis, again, I was at a conference, I was presenting a poster
on the cholesterol work in the health professionals, and she said, "You know, we
did measure cholesterol on everybody in the PCPT."
So then we looked together in the PCPT, and same thing, we found that
men who had lower levels of cholesterol on this axis.
So men who had lower levels
were less likely to have high-grade prostate cancer.
Okay, this has now been seen many times.
And then working with Ed more recently, and with one of his students,
and what she did is she extended the follow-up
of ARIC, the Health Professionals Follow-up Study, and she also did a meta-analysis
of 23 studies that had reported on this association.
And so with additional follow-up of the health professionals comparing the highest
quartile of cholesterol to the lowest, she still sees a positive
association, and then the meta-analysis, which compared the highest versus
lowest group. They don't always do quintiles or quartiles.
They have different
categories, but again, a positive association.
So this is a pretty consistent finding.All right.
And then Michael Moroney, who was a doctoral student and postdoc with me,
he took a look at total cancer death.
So this is statin drug use in ARIC with total cancer death, as
well as obesity-associated cancers and smoking-associated cancers, and
noted inverse associations
with longer-term use for each of these.
All right, so the digoxin story.
So again, this is Bill and Vasan working with June Liu, and what they did, and
this is truly transdisciplinary. So Bill is just a thinker.
He always has great ideas, and when he gets an idea, if there's anything that we
could test in populations, he'll come running over to my office
and he'll say, "Hey."
He's always really excited. And typically, we can figure out a way to study
it. And so it's true collaboration. It's always very exciting to me.
So what they did is the first screen was just to figure out the
cytotoxic potential of the Johns Hopkins Drug
Library. Okay? They figured out which ones had the top hits.
They showed at least a 50% inhibition, and then they brought it into
a secondary screen.
And then they came to me, and we took a look at the health professionals. Okay?
And so the top hits, the first one was disulfiram, which is Antabuse.
We weren't able to study that in the health professionals.
But the second one was digoxin, which is a very old drug for the treatment of
congestive heart failure and arrhythmia.
It's a sodium-potassium ATPase inhibitor.
So we thought this was interesting, and then we noticed that there was another drug
that's a top hit that acted on the same pathway.
And then there was a third drug, which was not FDA approved, again,
in the same pathway that would've been a top hit had it been FDA approved.
So we thought this was an interesting one to pursue.
We were able to study it in the health professionals.
It was one of the drugs they were asked to report on.
And what we found was an inverse association, and the longer they used
the drug, the lower the risk, and this was true for organ-confined disease
as well as advanced or lethal disease.
Now, digoxin, you would not just give somebody digoxin.
It's too dangerous. But the pathway is a little bit interesting, I think.
Okay? And what's really great about this work, this is something that Bill pointed
out, is it's the power of coming together, so between the basic
science and the work that's the epidemiology, and it's sort of like
screening where you do two steps, right?
So you reduce the false positive rate by having done the drug screen
first. Okay. Others have studied this, and
overall, there seems to be a, it's sort of consistent, inverse
association. Now, this is an example where we need a lot more work
going back to the laboratory to try to figure out the mechanism.
Is it because it's
acting on that enzyme I mentioned, or is there something else? Okay.
The last bit, and I can't tell if we're actually out of time
or not. I know that's what it says.
Yeah.
But we had five extra minutes.
Couple minutes.
Couple minutes. So the last thing is take all reasonable opportunities.
I want to leave you with this message. Take all reasonable opportunities.
So at some point, I was contacted by Joe Koroshetz, who was in my
department. His colleague, Aaron Folsom, was doing a
study with his student on prostate cancer, and they
said they need a prostate cancer expert. Would I please collaborate with him?
I'm like, "Sure." Okay. So we did, and it's an interesting study, metabolic
syndrome associated with reduced risk of prostate cancer, and this is back
in 2006. Well, because of this,
when an opportunity came up from NCI
to enhance the infrastructure of the ARIC cohort, which is a
cardiovascular cohort,
we took that opportunity. So we applied for one of the cohort infrastructure
grants,
and so we were awarded in that first round.
So now we've been able to leverage the deep data that
have been collected. So this cohort's funded by NHLBI.
They have collected every sample you'd want.
They've measured every biomarker you would have wanted.
And so because they measured it on everybody, we were able to leverage
it for cancer. So now it's been a remarkable set of
studies that not just us, but many people have been able to do
using these resources. Okay, so multiple visits.
They have proteomics at three time points.
There's methylation at a couple of time points.
There's whole exome sequencing at two time points, and again,
blood, everything you could ever want. Okay.
There's even a dental exam. So at some point
along the way, Walter Willett was one of our advisors, and he said, "You need to
start having other people use this cohort." This is while we were
funded. And so I took that advice, and I knew about the dental exam,
and I reached out to Dominique Michaud, who was well-known for her research on
periodontal disease, and I said, "Hey,
I think you should propose to do some research in this cohort." This is during the
pandemic. Based on this work, she's now gotten a whole bunch of grants, including
she had an AACR grant that was collaborative with Carl Kelsey, who's shown
here, and me. And so just to show you her findings,
so here we go. Here's the relationship between
sort of moderate, severe periodontal disease and people who don't have any teeth.
They're edentulous, which can be
because of periodontal disease. So positive association, especially for
colorectal and lung cancer. And you might say, "Well, smoking causes periodontal
disease. That's all this is." Well, we'd taken that into account, but even in
never smokers, we see the same patterns.
So I think that's pretty exciting.
And then we thought, well, what about the particular bacteria?
Well, in this cohort, they had information on
antibodies to periodontal pathogens.
So Baijun Xiao was a student with me, and he took a look at that,
and what he found was a subset of the pathogens.
So these pathogens infect first before the ones you all know
about, which is P. gingivalis, right? That's the typical one you'd know about.
These orange ones form the biofilm that allow P.
gingivalis to build up on top. And so he found having antibodies
against the orange-Kransky decided to
color these by color to be able to highlight them.
So the orange bacteria are the ones that seem to be related to lung
cancer risk, including P. intermedia and P.
nigrescens. So again, leveraging a
cohort study.
Okay, so I think I'm going to stop here. And what I want to do...
Is there a way to jump ahead to the very end?
Or should I just do it myself?
I always have too much. That's just how I am.
All right. Let's see.
Keep going. No, I know. I always have too much. Keep going. Here we go.
Just go back one slide.
This is what I wanted to really highlight for you all, the takeaway.
I want us to think about how we go from epidemiology back to basic
science. To assess causation and to figure out whether these
mechanisms are actionable. Okay.
We don't have a strategy for this.
We don't know when to hand these off. Is it one study?
Do we have to have a consortium? Is it the quality of the evidence?
What do we need to do? How big of an association to
prioritize it?
Do we have to think about population impact before we prioritize it?
There's no strategy for funding this.
This is going to be costly.
Okay? And then how do we make sure that the models, the laboratory-based
models, are going to make sense for people? Okay.
So as a start, here's my call to action to all of you.
Make sure you network with basic scientists when you're at conferences like this
one. Okay. Be a matchmaker,
endorse basic and population scientists to each other, just like Ed
Giovanucci and Bill Nelson did for me and Angelo. Make sure you do that.
Okay? And then make sure you educate reviewers and funders about the
benefits of including basic and population aims in the same grant
application. Okay? So that's my call to action.
Lots of people to acknowledge, lots of money to acknowledge.
Okay? And I really want to thank AACR and the American Cancer
Society for this honor. And thanks to all of you for coming here
today. For those of you who collaborated with me, or who I've trained, or
who trained me, thank you so much. Really appreciate all that you've done.
Thank you.
Thank you for that wonderful summary of many years of hard work
into half an hour.
Yep.
I think we've got time for a couple of questions.
Does anybody want to... There aren't any
questions from the online audience.
I will ask one question.
Okay. Is Ed right there? Is that Ed? Oh, Ed is here.
Hey, Ed.
Yay.
Oh, there's a microphone. Do you have to-
Thanks, Ed.
Yay. Hi.
The
statin
prostate
link, you then looked at cholesterol levels, and it seems like it ought to be
around the other way, because people on statins have higher cholesterol than people
who are not on statins, even when they're on the statins.
But their cholesterol is lowering, and we're thinking it may be the lowering
that's also important.
It's the change.
It could be the change, yeah.
But then how would that just relate to serum cholesterol?
It doesn't seem like you'd get anything, because people's
cholesterol gets more as they get older, so is there anybody out there
whose cholesterol is lowering without
taking statins?
Probably not. That's probably not the case.
Phew.
So it's an interesting question. So we did try to look at joint categories.
And also for the cholesterol findings, we have removed people that
were taking a cholesterol-lowering drug.
So I'm not answering your question directly.
Yeah.
But
we do see the cytotoxic activity of
statins.
That's why-
I think we take one question, and then we'll have to stop
... we need basic science, right?
Just one question.
That's why we need to be able to translate back. Yes. Hey there.
Hi. So just one question about the telomere length project.
The timing to measure telomere length is always tricky.
How do you make sure you measure telomere length
before the... I was just curious, did you measure the
telomere length before the onset of the prostate cancer?
So the studies that I showed at first, these men already had
prostate cancer. And what we were looking for was progression
from clinically localized disease to either
metastatic disease or death from prostate cancer.
In the study that I showed very quickly, that's in the prostate cancer
prevention trial,
we measured
in the stromal cells, not in the cancer cells.
And we had some men that didn't have prostate cancer and some men who did.
So we're not looking in the epithelial cells or the cancer
cells when we're looking at risk. We're looking in the stromal cells.
Okay. Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Okay. I'm afraid, I think we're out of time.
You can come up and ask afterwards, yeah.
So I'd once again like to
ask for a round of applause for Elizabeth.
I think it was a great talk, fantastic career.
Thanks, everyone.
And well done.
All right. Very good.